[Musique]
il a créé son mouvement générations
après avoir porté sans grand succès les
couleurs du parti socialiste à la
présidentielle benoît hamon est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté donc
l'invitation de la fp2e lcp de public
sénat et du figaro où nous nous trouvons
ce soir deux parlementaires un député la
république en marche et un sénateur les
républicains viendront vous interpellez
benoît hamon dans moins d'une vingtaine
de minutes maintenant d'abord yves
thréard du figaro et baptiste becquart
de l' agence france-presse bonsoir
messieurs on a envie de parler d'abord
avec vous benoît hamon qui avait été un
éphémère ministre de l'éducation
nationale je rappelle quelques mois de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
notamment bien sûr ce professeur de
créteil qui a été braqué par un élève et
c'est l'éducation qui est mise en joue
avec e.on annonce aujourd'hui donc un
plan d'action que préparent les
ministres castaner et blanc caire le
ministre de l'éducation nationale évoque
bien sûr des nouvelles et des mesures
éducatives et également d éventuellement
des sanctions il parle de
responsabilisation des familles qu'est
ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'il est nécessaire pour mettre un
terme à une forme d'impunité dans les
établissements scolaires bon la première
chose c'est qu'il faut dire que c'est
évidement insoutenables et inacceptable
de voir on puisse filmer par un de ses
camarades
alice et un braquet même si c'était avec
un pistolet factice l'enseignante elle
ne sait pas si c'est factice ou pas donc
il vous imaginez le traumatisme qu'elles
sont professeurs et avec ce sentiment
d'impunité qui veut qu'en plus on en
rigole en se faisant filmer et donc ça
appelle évidemment des sanctions à
l'endroit des jeunes en question
éducative ou pénales ah ben l'occurrence
la haye
une plainte qui étaient déposées en
justice et qui peut justifier un peu
plus qu'un conseil de discipline quand
on est là dans des menaces de mort on
est haut ça va évidemment plus loin donc
il y a il faut commencer par ça ensuite
dire que moi j'ai été ministre de
l'éducation nationale on a un rapport
hebdomadaire quotidien sur les faits qui
peuvent être liés à une petites
incivilités jusqu'à des actes graves et
j'étais moi même ministre de l'éducation
nationale et je pourrai vous le rappelez
quand une enseignante une institutrice a
été tué dans sa salle de classe
s'appelait fabienne terral calmette
c'était à albi en école primaire on
était tout près des vacances scolaires
par une parente d'élèves qui l'avait
assassiné au couteau dans sa propre
classe donc aujourd'hui l'école n'est
pas protégée n'est pas un sanctuaire
absolue contre les actes de violence ou
la violence de l'association carré plan
d'action s'impose mais je voudrais
simplement dire une chose
à cette étape j'entends on parle ça
communique beaucoup du côté du
gouvernement
j'espère qu'on va pas faire que
communiquer mais la première chose qu'il
faudrait dire et faire aujourd'hui c'est
de suspendre immédiatement la mesure de
suppression 1800 postes dans le
secondaire et 2400 l'année prochaine
parce que allez vous me dire que dans
des établissements on a des classes de
35 à 40 élèves parmi lesquels des élèves
qui ne suivent pas ou mal est court il
soit possible de tenir une s'agit d'une
absence
il voulait absolument me sens en
confiance et que c'est que manifestement
aujourd'hui la priorité pour moi oui
c'est déjà de répondre en arrêtant de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient moins d'un
mois quand il était ministre de
l'éducation nationale et on a la parole
qui se libèrent des enseignants
aujourd'hui avec un hashtag pas de
vagues qui se plaint enfin ces
enseignants à tous niveaux d'ailleurs se
plaignent en disant on est régulièrement
confronté alors peut-être pas des actes
aussi graves que celui de la semaine
dernière à créteil et notre hiérarchie
c'est à dire le rectorat l'académie le
j'imagine le ministère de l'éducation
nationale mais vous allez nous dire si
c'est vrai 1 2-10 surtout ne bougez pas
je vais pas parler à la place de blanc
coeur public sur sa politique à lui
oui mais j'étais rassuré une chose c'est
qu'il n'y a jamais eu une seule
instruction qu à part quand j'étais
ministre de la part de mon cabinet au
chef d'établissement au rectorat sur le
thème faites taire ou dissimulé les
violences de l'établissement résister à
ne pas convoquer les conseils de dc ont
des mérites mais il peut y avoir des
politiques établissement par
établissement qu'on peut interroger
mais attention quand même nom mais
est-ce que je suis ravi que vous
écoutiez les professeurs quand il s'agit
quand ils écrivent sur twitter quand ils
vous disent ceci beaucoup plus
régulièrement qu'ils manquent eux
d'adultes et d'autres profs dans leur
établissement écouter les aussi enfin
pourquoi je lui ai dit non mais ça
évidemment pas que alors je veux point
une chose là on parle le ministre de
l'intérieur condamné soutien scolaire
on a de moins en moins de médecins
scolaires les médecins scolaires ils
servent à quoi
à détecter des enfants ou des
adolescents qui ont des troubles du
comportement
parce que moi je veut pointer une chose
quand même quand on est un jeune qui
braque son prof pour une histoire
présence c'est qu'il a manifestement les
troubles du comportement à mes yeux et
les comportements qui ne sont pas
normaux je pense aussi que ce travail
des adultes cpe surveillants médecin
scolaire
tout ce travail est indispensable
j'ajoute qu'on avait commencé le travail
de sécurisation des établissements après
les attentats de charlie et ceux de
novembre et du bataclan donc ce travail
a été fait commandeur de manière très
consciente sur les dangers ce travail
avait été fait sur la nécessité de
vérifier que n'importe quel objet ne
rendent pas dans les établissements
conçoit un portique
oui mais non mais t'es portique bas mais
la question mais écoutez moi je ne crois
pas qu'aujourd'hui ça ne change rien
vous avez aux états unis ont fait des
portiques les plus grands massacres dans
les écoles ont eu lieu aux états unis à
faire des téléphones portables est ce
que pour vous c'est une mesure qui peut
être suffisante alors je vais me calmer
ses six mois pour le fait qu' il ya des
gamins qui soit arrivée à leur écran
en classe onze autres les cas ce stress
près comme ça pâton romeo parfois mais
rarement mais évidemment moi évidemment
ça me choque comme tout le monde
ce que je crains c'est que c'est qu'à la
fin on est plus que ça c'est à dire qu'
il n'y est pas il ya l'interdiction des
portables mais toujours pas plus
d'adultes toujours pas plus de prisons
sur le nombre d'enseignants et
encadrants crois je veux dire mais son
sens alors sans l'ombre d'une communauté
sans idéologie aucune je pense
aujourd'hui que oui on demande à la
police et aux collèges et aux écoles
publiques de prendre en charge des
inégalités une pauvreté des cycles en
effet la v5 rappeler leur oui je sais
54000 qu'on a créé postes de profs mais
honnêtement avec la réforme des
retraites qui se prépare et la prise en
compte des non pas des rames dans un
calcul des retraites qui va prendre
toute la carrière soit nommé sans les
primes
vous allez avoir non mais je le dis vous
allez avoir parmi lesquels et les
carrières les moins attractives nous ne
sont pas pour les postes de profs si la
retraite monsieur benjamin gayraud matin
a dit il faut responsabiliser les
parents d'élèves là dessus eric ciotti
qui avait déjà engagé cette politique
dans son département des alpes-maritimes
dit il faut suspendre les allocations
familiales aux parents de ces enfants
turbulents va plus que turbulent qui se
livrent un violent alors qu'on va pas
que ce soit la solution non mais non moi
je ne crois pas l'arrêt des gens
oui il faudrait la réaliser les parents
évidemment et mais vous comptez
remontant met d'accord mais arrêtez de
vous prendre peu de vous mettre à la
place des parents et penser que vous
êtes plus responsable que de quel droit
aussi non mais vous savez ce que c'est
la souffrance d'une maman célibataire k5
môme et qui voit un de ces mômes partir
en vrille comme ça bon oui elle est là
elle a perdu le contrôle et c'est en lui
supprimant les allocations familiales
que vous allez régler le problème mais
je pense que ce n'est pas sérieux et de
la part de gens qui sont d'ailleurs
pourrait se poser la question
tout ce bien sous tous rapports et leurs
enfants ne pose aucun problème aucun
problème dans les lycées eux mêmes
arrêtons cette forme de condescendance
des gens
bien sous tous rapports qui voudraient
responsabiliser les familles les plus
pauvres en leur supprimant les
allocations familiales jeunes moi je
vous la firme ça n'est pas la solution
cela étant dit on à des dispositifs pour
aider les parents aujourd'hui à
comprendre ce qu'il se passe à essayer
de reprendre le contrôle de leurs gamins
mais objectivement pour avoir été
confronté à cette parfois grande
pauvreté grande précarité de certaines
familles vous pouvez avoir des parents
extrêmement volontaire et qui ont perdu
le contrôle des mômes perdu le contrôle
des enfants et je ne crois pas
qu'aujourd'hui leur dire écoutez on va
vous supprimer les allocations
familiales résolve quoi que ce soit
c'est vrai que le problème c'est pas 10
le salaire des professeurs c'est à dire
qu'en fait voilà les élèves se sentent
que le métier de professeur n'est plus
désirable et du coup ils le font payer
indirectement aux professeurs
abbas qui est certain c'est que quand
vous commencez une carrière aujourd'hui
dans l'éducation nationale c'est on est
moins bien payés en france qu'on ne les
dans les pays voisins
ça va me en fin de carrière parce que la
progression de carrière est meilleur
mais la réalité c'est que y'a pas
beaucoup vous présenter les mois de
titulaire d'un m2 en mathématiques qui
choisissent la carrière de prof de maths
pour le salaire c'est pareil pour toutes
les disciplines
donc la question de la carrière elle est
fondamentale mais je rajoute la réforme
des retraites et la retraite par points
elle va fragiliser spécifiquement ces
professions si en plus au terme d'une
vie passée à servir la nation dans
l'école vous avez une retraite une
retraite de misère ce sera encore moins
attractifs donc intéressons-nous
effectivement aujourd'hui à
l'attractivité du métier merveilleux on
va parler peut-être maintenant d'une
autre violence politique
oui juste avant le service génère qui
vient d'être nommé ministre de
l'intérieur il aurait dû monter au
créneau tout de suite sur ce sujet il
avait une interview dans le journal du
dimanche notre confrère hier sur deux
pages il n'a pas parlé
un seul instant de ce qui s'est passé
dans ce qu'il sait de créteil en
revanche et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui a pris le taureau par les
cornes
vous trouvez ça normal moi je pense les
faits pour le poste casta mais je pense
qu'on a misé intérieur qui n'est pas sûr
de grands choses notamment sur ce qui
relève des
politique de sécurité moi je me réjouis
de la formation continue des dix régions
de la république en marche
je ne sais pas si au ministère de
l'intérieur ce soit le bon endroit pour
faire de la formation continue voilà ce
soir a été mieux d'avoir un ministre qui
avait une doctrine une idée une
politique vous avez l'âge est désolant
c'est quand même un spécialiste oui ça
ne nous rassure pas beaucoup voyez vous
non mais attendez moi je
pardon mais soit on est dans un moment
qui est un moment grave
vous êtes venu ses commanditaires c'est
pas que je deviens sécuritairement je
m'attache à l'efficacité des politiques
de sécurité sur le sioniste honneur lui
l'ordre public et la sécurité pour tous
ça m'intéresse que chacun se sente en
sécurité qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres
ça m'intéresse moi juste que je souhaite
c'est que ces politiques soit efficace
enfin c'est un carrosse il alors mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que et là
pourquoi alors belge pour faire de la
politique sans doute en tout cas c'est
ce que le président de la république le
lui demande
mais qu'il soit flanqué d'un
professionnel compétent
c'est quand même assez curieux qu'on
soit obligé de faire des binômes avec un
politique un professionnel compétent
ça suppose que l'un n'est pas politique
le professionnel compétent et que nos
politiques ne prennent pas compétent je
voulais parler donc de jean luc
mélenchon comment est ce que vous avez
vécu cette semaine survoltée du leader
de la france insoumise est-ce que ce que
vous avez regardé comme nous tous vous a
conforté dans l'image que vous avez de
jean luc mélenchon vous l'avez traité de
populiste
non c'est lui qui se revendique
populiste jetterai pas c'est lui qui a
une stratégie populiste qui est
théorisée par des philosophes chantal
mouffe j'appartiens au débat politique
donc non il ya 2,2 moment moi je
comprends l'émotion qui peut naître
d'une perquisition spectaculaire et du
sentiment qu'on vient fouiller dans des
fichiers dans
le travail d'un parti politique
d'opposition et conçoit légitimement se
sentent humiliés par cela mais je dis
aussi pas de passe droit non plus dans
la république ni humiliation ni
passe-droits et si je peux comprendre la
colère qui peut naître de ce sentiment
d'humiliation
je ne comprends absolument pas vous le
dis les attaques qui ont été les
attaques contre la presse à part cela
pas sacré cv qu'il dira mais ce qui est
sacré par non mais c'est en l'occurrence
ceux sous j'ai envie de dire non mais on
pourra parler des professeurs on en
parlait avant ça c'est ça crée
évidemment la parlementaire doit pouvoir
agir et il est protégé par l'immunité
parlementaire sans être en permanence
menacés dans l'exercice de sa fonction
mais au-delà de ces mots là en france
comme dans les grandes démocraties le
quatrième pouvoir celui de la presse il
est indispensable et précieux moi j'ai
eu des désaccords avec des journalistes
ça m'a fâché parfois des papiers je leur
ai même dit mais stop à la mise en cause
de la presse
stop à la mise en cause des journalistes
comme une catégorie en soi d'individus
qui ré ou servir le pouvoir aurait comme
fonction est trop loin ah oui je me l'a
été oui mais moi je pense qu'on a besoin
d'eux un tempérament mais celui des
victimes comme la vie je suis hollande
ou est ce que il ya eu voilà c'est des
sinistrés qui réfléchit en cas de
confrontation aurait fait une stratégie
écologique ou psycho à un problème qui
n'est pas ce ne sera que le film mais
non ils enchantent politique ne sera
fait je ne sais pas c'est une stratégie
je dis que c'est politique moi je ne
veux pas psychologiquement presa
politique je ne crois pas même s'il
connaissait pas le tempérament de jean
luc mélenchon sait que ce qu'il dit et
ce qu'il fait fa cup et je lui ai jeu et
je lui prête d'être intelligents et
responsables donc je dis quoi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
dans le moment politique que nos
questions laissons à la fois de dignité
je le dis de dignité et de respect des
institutions même si nous voulons les
changer mais tant qu'elles sont là nous
devons tant pour la justice que pour
l'état que pour la presse les respecter
ce qui n'empêche pas le débat et moi je
le souhaite vigoureux je le souhaite
même que nul tu veux mais respectueux et
je le dis d'autant plus que jean luc
mélenchon le voit on a une instabilité
du président la république qui se
comporte comme un sorte d'enfant roi
avec les institutions
fort mal mais je bon oui je le trouve je
considère qu'il ya quelque chose qui
relève de 2,2 voilà de comportement un
peu immature en jouissant des
institutions et en convoquant
systématiquement où l'ancien régime en
jour où l' empire un autre ou des
symboles qui sont censés manifestants
mais moi j'adore l'histoire de france il
s'avère que je m'en délecte tous les
jours mais de là à singer la puissance
d'un louis xiv d'un bonaparte ou d'un
clemenceau à quoi cela sert-il
surtout si c'est pour faire la
manifestation de son impuissance ne
serait ce déjà qu'à mettre en oeuvre son
propre projet politique ou à protéger
les retraités
voilà donc je vais te dire moi je reste
très jolie phrase de hugo qui dit un
singe qui me train ligne ça restera
toujours un sa valeur donc moi je ne
veux je pense qu'on aura des
institutions de la vème que l'on célèbre
lll singes la puissance là où en réalité
elle elle consacre le mythe d'un homme
providentiel qui n'est jamais sûr on l'a
stressé quand alors que vous voulez dire
précisément avec l'enfant roi et de ce
que vous voulez dire de jean luc
mélenchon il ya un espace énorme alors
pour vous puisque soudain gbagbo rivaux
qui s'appelle jean luc mélenchon avec
qui vous n'avez jamais beaucoup frayer
il faut le dire
et puis monsieur macron qui n'est pas
votre tasse de thé ben là vous devriez
pouvoir vous mais j'ai pas nous et vous
mais vous vous avez raison c'est en tout
cas une responsabilité une
responsabilité que ça me donne et que ça
nous donne à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont déjà pas envie de participer au
match truqué des européennes entre les
deux parties qui sont en train de tuer
l'europe à petit feu les libéraux qui
continue j'écoutais encore pierre
moscovici ce matin par rapport à
l'italie bhutto qui remerciait la macro
oui bon on n'est pas obligé de les
croire non plus mais qui aujourd'hui
prépare la fin de l'europe dès lors
qu'elles ne se résume qu'à des
politiques d'austérité de libre échange
on accepte des traités de libre échange
qui font entrer des produits dont on
sait que sur le plan environnemental ils
sont dangereux en europe bref ça n'a pas
de sens et ceux qui n'ont pas à petit
feu mais de manière radicale
prépare à une sortie de l'europe en
disant l'europe ça n'est pas bon par
essence par nature là où moi je vous dis
oui je ne suis pas d'accord avec le
fonctionnement des traités européens je
ne souhaite plus démocratique
oui je me désespère des politiques
libérales et des régulations et vous
allez je pense que la démocratie
européenne ça a du sens sinon après tout
je me pourrait faire le même
raisonnement sur la france la
constitution de la vème république ne me
va pas les politiques libérales ne me
vont pas ben je jette aussi la france et
que les politiques libérales nom alors
je suis citoyen vous allez y boxer dans
ce match et européennes si je comprends
bien à quelle position alors boxer n'est
peut-être pas le bon terme parce que je
m'appelle pas c'est la réponse que je
trouve que il frère a posé une question
très juste et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y aura pas de reconstruction de la
gauche qui se fasse son solution et si
je devais dire une chose aujourd'hui ça
pendant 30 secondes
mais par rapport aux défis climatiques
je serais à la place d'emmanuel macron
je me souviendrai d'un de ses illustres
prédécesseurs n'ont pas en france nos
états unis qui un jour a mis la nation
américaine devant un objectif comparé à
1 qui paraissait inaccessible il a dit
dans dix ans les états unis d'amérique
seront sur la lune c'était john
fitzgerald kennedy
huit ans plus tard il était sur la lune
aujourd'hui faire la france où une
économie zéro carbone en 2050 c'est
possible c'est possible en mobilisant
qui les entrepreneurs les ingénieurs les
chercheurs les étudiants l'ensemble de
la population sur l'économie circulaire
sur les mobilités sur le logement sur
l'agriculture nous pouvons y arriver il
y aurait quelque chose d'incroyable à ce
qu'enfin on recrée une communauté de
destin autour d'un objectif laisser à
nos enfants un monde dans lequel la
dette écologique soit moins forte demain
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
parce que c'est ça aux européennes bas
c'est de ça dont je parlerai avec
beaucoup d'autres et c'est ce qui fait
que je m'engagerais je l' ai déjà dit
totalement dans cette date alors bonjour
la gamme n'est pas répondu là c'est ma
réponse va oui mais nous satisfait pas
serait-elle de l'île et vous mériterez
le motive à écouter avec logiciel
moselle qui avait peut-être de disques à
préciser certaines choses
vous avez parlé de jean luc mélenchon il
ya caractère complotistes dans ce qu'il
ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui en disant c'est
un complot contre moi c'est un 1er qu'on
a entendu aussi à l'extrême droite
est-ce que vous tiriez un signe égal
entre nom jean luc mélenchon et madame
le pen envoyer les similitudes et donc
ses militants moi je sais faire la
différence entre l'engagement d'une vie
de jean luc mélenchon à gauche et
l'engagement d'une autre vie le point
noir eu le mot gauche et ne veut plus
j'ai bien compris c'est bien ce qui fait
notre désaccord et samassa m'a pas aidé
moi j'assume d'être de gauche et de
vouloir rassembler ma famille politique
non c'est pas ça c'est que mais je fais
une différence et je vous ne trouverez
jamais à faire un signe égal entre deux
familles qui après tout quand même
défendre des choses radicalement
différente notamment en termes de roi
emmanuel maurel et mais madame lienemann
qui sont partis du parti socialiste pour
se rapprocher monsieur mélenchon sont
pas bues vers vous mais il vous
l'appliquez clairement là ouais ben moi
je raisonne pas en part de marché
écoutez les noms mais je vais vous dire
les scissions de parti en crise
honnêtement ça peut être très
intéressant fait n'est pas comme ça que
je raisonne moi je ne me si je devais
fondé ou parier
que la gauche va se reconstruire sur la
base des parts de marché des uns et des
autres ça ne m'intéresse pas bon voilà
il y en a qui font commerce de ses parts
de marché moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la manière de commercer disent qu'ils
ont un grand projet il veut le faire le
front populaire du 21e siècle
mais là encore c'est intéressant
populaire mais c'est que j'aimerais bien
que on imagine la gauche pas seulement
dans la nostalgie alors les grandes
dates 45 la sécurité sociale 36 le front
populaire
mais est ce que ça dit en quoi que ce
soit comment repenser le travail est ce
que ça dit en quoi que ce soit comme on
pense la transition écologique et la
nécessité de changer nos modes de
production et de consommation
est ce que ça dit en quoi on va demain
penser différemment bas la sécurité
sociale et notamment le revenu universel
d'existence comme un moyen justement
d'assurer un nouveau rapport au travail
et à la régression sociale
votre discours de terne où l'islam est
ce que je vous dis simplement c'est que
bombe à la nostalgie c'est bien je
préfère encore ceux qui modestement se
tourner vers l'avenir
la suite avec nos deux parlementaires
qui vont faire la rentrée sur ce plateau
vous allez les découvrir merci messieurs
merci merci messieurs bonne soirée
bonsoir et donc les deux parlementaires
sont ces gens-là rebond soir vous êtes
député la république en marche de paris
je voulais saluer monsieur le député et
philippe dominati sénateur les
républicains de paris n'a parlé de
l'éducation nationale de ce qui se passe
dans les écoles c'est grave on l'a vu il
ya un instant
sylvain maillard vous vouliez revenir
sur l'éducation nationale si on
permettait faudrait juste faire une
vraie une petite aparté mais qui me
semblent importantes
vous avez peut-être penser que c'est
quelque chose d'à nex mais c'est quelque
chose pour moi qui ne n'est pas léger
revenir sur l'écriture inclusive
je vois que dans votre le nom de votre
de votre parti c'est de l'écriture
inclusive mais de façon plus générale
vous utilisez sont très souvent dans
votre acte l'écriture inclusive
l'écriture inclusive c'est une écriture
qui est pour les malvoyants les non
voyants de ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
lisible c'est à dire qu'avec
l'utilisation des machines braille ne
peut pas être lisible donc c'est une
écriture qui porte très mal son nom
moi je je comprends que cette écriture
est devenu au fur et à mesure un repaire
de gauche en disant je fais une réunion
publique comprend des tracts avec une
écriture inclusive on appelle donc c'est
quelque chose qui appelle à une comme
signe de reconnaissance des gens de
gauche des électeurs éventuellement de
gauche moi je voudrais je vous en parle
parce que avec plusieurs parlementaires
nous sommes allés voir edouard philippe
il ya un an parce que nous utilisions
aussi au début une l'écriture inclusive
et je lui ai dit comme j'ai comme
d'autres ont pu lui dire il faut arrêter
d'utiliser cette créature parce qu'elle
n'est pas inclusive pour les personnes
en situation de handicap
moi j'aimerais avoir votre avis dessus
je ne sais pas si vous le sachet saviez
que ça essayer pour les personnes qui
sont non voyants et malvoyants
c'est un vrai souci pour eux et que si
c'est n'est pas le cas je suis heureux
de vous le dire
et j'aimerais en tout cas de mon point
de vue que vous n'utilisez plus merci
pour cet
recommandations si nous le savions pas
ce que nous avons été nous mêmes
sollicités ou saisis par des malvoyants
au sein de notre organisation et autres
qu'à travers leur association sur le
fait effectivement qui avec elle ne
remplissait pas l'écriture inclusive
leurs fonctions dès lors qu'elle mettait
à l'écart des personnes qui ont un
handicap moi je suis pas dans une
situation de matic vis-à-vis de cette
option là ce qui me préoccupe
aujourd'hui c'est de faire en sorte que
nous luttions contre toutes les formes
de stéréotypes de genre contre tous les
préjugés qui peuvent exister et dès le
plus jeune âge c'est un sujet sur
lesquels j'aimerais vous répondre et
élargir un petit peu la discussion
j'avais été très frappé avant même
d'être ministre de l'éducation nationale
sur la façon dont canton s'était
intéressé à la formation des maîtres
cance des professeurs des écoles et ont
notamment en maternelle sur la façon
dont ils véhiculent et eux mêmes des
stéréotypes de genre et de la façon dont
on répartissait inconsciemment les
classes entre garçons et filles et dont
la manière dont on enseigne et n'était
pas si inclusive que ça et je pense
qu'on doit mobiliser tous les
instruments et tous les moyens après la
confiance en soi mais oui oui et c'est
pour ça que nous avons à l'écriture mais
je suis là dessus c'est un point précis
sur lequel il ya une vraie de l'accusé
c'est une faiblesse de cette réponse là
je ne sais pas les étals pour les voyant
la question est maintenant comment
est-ce qu'on répond à ce qu étaient les
objectifs de l'écriture inclusive sur la
lutte contre les inégalités et les
discriminations et comment on s'attache
à ce qu'elle ne soit pas à travers un
objectif louable et bien qu'elle n'ait
pas des résultats qui rajouta contraire
à ces prêts côté nominative employant 10
personnes en situation de handicap
oui moi je vous ai écouté avec fougue
mais je me posais une question de
politique parce que je vous ai entendu
parler encore il ya quelques instants de
l'éducation nationale ça me remet
quelques années en arrière
je vous ai entendu faire une définition
du libéralisme et j'ai le sentiment
qu'il n'ya pas de d'acquis d'expérience
que vous n'avez pas tiré les leçons de
ce qui s'est passé après un exercice au
gouvernement après un mandat louper et
puis après un score je dirais
catastrophique pour 1 go pour une
formation gouvernementale
vous repartez à la bataille sans faire
le bilan de ce qui s'est passé vous avez
parlé du libéralisme
pour moi le libéralisme il n'existe pas
dans ce pays il ya des socialistes
il ya des socialistes qui étaient dans
un premier temps avec françois hollande
comme vous et comme macron et puis après
il ya les socialistes qui se sont
divisés qui ont perdu le pouvoir qui ont
mis la france dans cette situation
économique difficile
vous y avez participé à peine vous avez
perdu votre mandat de député vous créer
un nouveau mouvement socialiste une
tendance du socialisme et vous dites
maintenant macro est un libéral pour moi
c'est pas du tout un libéral c'est un
socialiste c'est un socialiste qui a
brûlé pendant cinq ans qui a été
ministre de françois hollande comme vous
et vous faites une définition du
libéralisme alors tout le programme que
vous proposez avec quel argent est il
fait vous êtes candidat par exemple à
l'élection présidentielle pour les
primaires vous dites je suis pour le
revenu universel
pendant l'élection présidentielle vont
aimer vous dise il faut l'abandonner
c'est pas raisonnable
donc vous ne l'assumé pas en tant que
candidat à la présidence de la
république et quelques semaines après
lorsque vous créez votre mouvement vous
reprenez un nouveau ce programme avec
quel argent
avec quels impôts est ce que vous
trouvez que la france n'a pas abcès
d'impôts et de prélèvements obligatoires
j'aurais voulu poser beaucoup de
questions a cédé non il y en avait mais
en l'honneur avec le libéralisme
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on n'en
connaît pas la définition
bon je vais revenir à la question la
plus importante celle qui nous permet de
nous tourner vers l'avenir parce que
d'inventaire du
quinquennat moi je crois que les faits
dans mon programme d'élection
présidentielle était une manière de
tourner la page du quinquennat parce
qu'il vous a pas échappé qu'il n'était
défendu par absolument aucun ministres
du précédent gouvernement
donc bon ou quasiment pas donc revenons
à cette question du revenu universel
moi ma conviction d'abord je n'ai pas
abandonné au présentiel c'est pas vrai
on a cherché à le mettre en oeuvre une
première étape et je ne nie pas je ne
nie pas que sur ces questions là nous
sommes face à un défi qui nous amène à
penser une nouvelle protection sociale
il apparaît c'est le principal reproche
que je fais à l'actuel gouvernement et
aujourd'hui il apparaît que nous ne
serons plus financé demain notre
protection sociale
si les cotisations continue est assis
sur le travail pourquoi parce qu' il
n'existe pas une seule étude qui disent
le contraire de ce qui va suivre la
totalité des études qui se penche sur la
transformation du travail nous disent
qu'un métier sur deux ou un emploi sur
deux sera transformé par la révolution
numérique et qu'entre 10 et 20 % de ces
emplois seront détruits
alors on a toujours des commandes ird et
des gens très convaincu qu'il vaut 10
grâce à l'innovation technologique
on créera plus d'emplois que on en aura
détruit ce qui ce passe temps mais payés
qui sont très robotisée
j'observe que les pays très robotisée
comme la corée par exemple ont mis en
place une fiscalité sur les robots qu'on
me reprochait de vouloir mettre en place
pays le plus robotisée je voulais au
passage donc moi ce que je pense ce que
je crois profondément c'est qu'il faut
anticiper cette transformation et
travail liés à la révolution numérique
et que si demain je vous pose la
question
nous nous trouvons une grande surface
dans laquelle nous remplaçons 20
personnes qui travaillaient aux caisses
parvint portique l'entreprise économise
un salaire elle économise évidemment les
cotisations sociales
ces cotisations sociales ne sont plus
non plus payé par le salarié puisqu'il
n'est plus employé
pourtant cette entreprise dégage
toujours autant de richesses des cieux
comme africa la place le logisticien non
mais je vous le dire simplement exemple
si nous sommes maintenant vers
l'occurrence comment cette entreprise
coty stèle sa nomination
contribuent-elles au financement de la
solidarité réponse vous n'irez
c'est là le sujet c'est que j'ai envie
de vous dire je ne sais pas je me moque
de savoir si vous êtes libéraux pas
libéraux si monsieur mayer les
socialistes se fera je sais pas comment
un long débat tout le monde s'en moque
que vous soyez en 10 sec et savez vous
vous allez probable serre et pouf et
d'être présent ce que vous ne pouvez pas
financer ça c'est très simple c'est ça
le revenu social universel c'est à peu
près 35 milliards ou plus ou moins selon
les chiffres on est le pays le plus
fiscalisé où il ya le plus de pression
fiscale
il ya eu le ras-le-bol fiscal et vous
vous continuez à promettre je semble
pouvoir délivrer monsieur est inapte et
ça c'est problématique on déclare ce
savant mélange à la crédibilité
je vous écoute mais diable écoutez moi
je mangeais vous dis qu'on remplace que
ce qui m'insupporte
on augmente la csg donc la fiscalité sur
les retraités ou estime que je trouve
inadmissible je vais vous dire les
pensions elle veut continuer à chercher
comment les revenus et vous allaitez du
capital on est d'accord mais vous êtes
bien des indexées les pensions par
rapport à l'inflation donc ça veut dire
que les augmenterai moins que les prix
donc ça c'est une réalité
moi je vous dis si demain mon entreprise
toujours à remplacer les salariés par
des portiques
oui et qu'elles contribuent moins la
fluorite et allez vous me dire que mon
père à l'épandage écoutait déjà sur un
produit qui est vendu et dans une
économie qui marche et à la tva et un
cinquième du groupe du produit va à
l'état par la tva donc une économie
florissante
c'est l'imposition déjà je dirais par la
tv et sociales water donc l'heureux
dressera taxe est aussi mon oreille moi
je propose que nous sommes novices les
hommes soient mises à l'encan joie
depuis ses 8 ans et l'a payée par les
retraités les consommateurs utilisant
non jeudi dans une école oui par contre
là je dis vous avez des recettes pour un
état tout simplement et ça se produit
dans un certain nombre de pays depuis
sept ans nous avons le même taux
d'imposition en france est ce que vous
vous proposer d'aller encore plus loin
se déplacer la mesure
j'ai une vraie différence par rapport à
monsieur dominati et je préfère tout de
suite le dira moi je pense que dans
votre exemple un très bon exemple
d'ailleurs qu'on vit au milieu à paris
nous sommes élus de paris l'un et
l'autre on le vit exactement à leurs
actes et dans le 8e arrondissement
c'est emploi de caissière d'agents de
caisse sont remplacés par des logiciels
et des emplois de logisticiens céder
d'autres emplois ça veut pas dire que
l'emploi frontale qui disparaît
peut-être transformer avoué me dire mais
c'est peut-être d'autres personnes
et c'est pour ça qu'on a porté cette loi
avenir professionnel moi je l'honneur de
la porter en disant on va monter en
compétences et on va accompagner tout au
long de sa vie des évolutions de
carrière parce que quelque part
peut-être que dans quand on réfléchit
bien à ce qu'il faut est-ce que c'est
pas plus intéressant plus constructif
dans sa vie d'être agent de casser
ensuite devenir logicien que tous savent
ils ont engendré un exemple très précis
la salle où il suit les dernières je
voudrais juste revenir je vous donne la
parole tout de suite quand vous dites la
csg moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
idée juste et heureux de porter cette
réforme en disant on augmente la csg
parce que je pense que tous les revenus
doivent contribuer à la protection
sociale et que quelque part offert
portait uniquement sur les salaires les
revenus et les parements la protection
sociale c'est une erreur et quelque part
ça va un peu dans votre sens de dire que
l'intégralité des revenus doivent être
axés pour permettre une protection
sociale est donc là dessus moi je suis
un peu surpris que vous soyez offusqué
sur l'augmentation de la csg parce que
quelque part ça va dans votre sens ça va
pas dans mon sens ça va pas dans mon
sens qu'on ne savait pas équilibré par
la mise en place d'une fiscalité
autrement plus innovantes qui est celle
expérimenté par doute je le rappelle la
corée qui pense la mise à contribution
de la machine quand elle crée de la
richesse
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais
d'un mot puisque vous m'avez pris un
exemple qui était très juste c'est là où
franchement les avocats doux
nouveau monde je vous trouve du timide
dans votre radicalité de votre rupture
et votre disruption parce que
fondamentalement les grands géant de la
logistique qui vous ont pas attendu
amazon est en train d'expérimenter dans
ces hangars comme en termes de livraison
des mises en place des systèmes 100%
100% que j'y viens de 100% fondé sur la
technologie dans le hangar comme demain
le drone qui vous livrera donc votre
logis six sièges pas combien de temps il
va garder son job mais va pas le garder
longtemps la réalité de ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est que je pense
monsieur ailleurs que à la fondue
évidemment se pencher sur les métiers de
demain et donc avoir une politique est à
la fois une politique de formation
continue et initiale qui imaginent et
pensent tout cela mais moi j'observe que
ces innovations de rupture elles vont si
vite qu'elle nous prennent tous deux
vitesses et pourquoi est ce que je me
sens assez légitime à vous parler de
tout cela si j'étais mon discours était
totalement en rupture avec les grands
spécialistes de ces questions
moi je vous dirai peut-être que je me
trompe mais quand vous avez elon musk
patron de tesla
bill gates patron de microsoft qui
préconise une fiscalité qui fait une
fiscalité fondé justement sur la
richesse créée par les machines et
l'intelligence artificielle est moins
sûr les hommes quand ils préconisent eux
aussi au regard des transformations du
travail un revenu universel je me dire
en tout cas que ce peut-être vous
d'informaticiens et qui ont pensé c'est
ces innovations eux
pour ce qui est de l'avenir pour
davantage comme moi que comme vous et je
vous invite à être un peu plus disruptif
dans votre manière de placer la
nationalité un mot là dessus et puis on
change de sujet moi j'aime bien les
exemples que vous prenez mais pourquoi
vous prenez pas leur modèle de société
leur modèle de fiscalité vous prenez
qu'un morceau mais pourquoi vous prenez
des entrepreneurs libéraux dans impayés
libérale où il n'ya pas d'impôt pour
vous appuyez votre exemple de la finir
c'est pour le moins curieux car nous
sommes exactement et que pour ça que ça
marche très bien là et mon fils qu'elle
a eu on est obligé d'avoir une situation
défensive une idée là nous affaiblissons
que connaissez vous ne tirez pas les
conséquences en cas en réalité de votre
expérience mais vous continuez à me
remettre à délivrer des promesses qu'ils
peuvent nous amener à l'incertaine
faire proche banlieue honnêtement
j'avais beaucoup de respect pour en plus
ce débat politique y compris les
positions vous pouvez prendre mais là
vous êtes un peu malhonnête avec moi moi
j'essaye de tirer des conséquences des
échecs de la gauche quand elle n'a qu'un
discours qui est de dire mon bain
finalement quand il s'agit de service
public on va faire une administration un
fonctionnaire un formulaire quand il
s'agit de paul et questionner ça je
pense que vous voulez de prélèvement
plus jeune est mort que je vous dise
l'échec de la gauche je ne veux pas
qu'ils reposent toujours qu'il va mal
mais je pense que c'est un but même si
vous avez une sorte de leitmotiv qui
tourne en boucle
moi je vous dit on mais sa réponse sur
qui tu es sur quoi alors voilà je
voterai pour me nommer ma réponse je
viens de le dire
oui je suis favorable car quand la
machine remplace l'homme et qu'elle crée
plus de richesses que l'homme qui était
à la place c'est c'est dommage que ça me
supprime s'assurer maine emploi et en
plus on cotise plus nos systèmes de
protecteur l'arjel qui va payer nos
retraites via les autres sujets quand
même une petite question quand même un
problème emmanuel macron il a proposé un
revenu universel d'activité ça vous
plaît pas à user rien à voir tout le
monde le sait que ça pas grand chose à
voir mais c'est le même nom c'est un
effort de simplification des minima
sociaux
c'est un rsa qui serait distribué avec
davantage de contreparties exigées du
bénéficiaire
donc moi avant de j'ai écouté le
discours j'étais pas très emballé je
vous avoue mais s'il reprend le revenu
universel dans le nom c'est sans doute
qu'il est informé que ce sujet préoccupe
beaucoup de nos compatriotes et qu'il
évolue dans les opinions publiques
européennes
puis après j'attends de voir
définitivement jeu je vais vous dire moi
je me demande de on nous demande des
fois de juger les uns et les autres sont
cons et
sylvain maillard vous êtes venus aussi
avec des questions sur l'éducation
nationale je le disais tout à l'heure
alors je vais rebondir de sursaut ce que
vous dit tout à l'heure sur
l'attractivité du métier de professeur
et je suis là dessus je pense que
peut-être on va s'y retrouver
si on réfléchit qu'on dit on paye
beaucoup plus les enseignants terre vous
en avez parlé on paye beaucoup plus pas
une prime une petite prime on paye
beaucoup plus les enseignants comme on
peut la voir en allemagne par exemple on
met on les suit on les forme beaucoup
plus que ce que l'on fait à l'heure
actuelle que les inspecteurs de
circonscription connaissent déjà les
profs et soit dans les écoles les
suivent beaucoup plus qu'il est un vrai
accompagnement et qu'en échange dans une
société de droits et de devoirs
on donne plus de droits pour les
professeurs mais plus de devoir c'est à
dire qui se forment une partie pendant
les vacances scolaires qui est beaucoup
de vacances scolaires une partie de
vacances scolaires est consacré à la
formation professionnelle tout au long
de leur vie avec l'accompagnement ça me
semble quelque chose de vue et que l'on
arrête de recruter au statut se dire
tout simplement que ceux qui ne sont pas
et vous le savez très bien que ce soit
rap wire des professeurs qui ne
correspondent pas qui ne sont pas
pleinement épanouie devant les classes
et qui parfois sont disons le d mauvais
profs ne soit plus protégé par un statut
mais dire tout simplement on les
encourage on les accompagne beaucoup
plus qu'à l'heure actuelle parce que
très souvent on laisse les professeurs
dans une classe de la ville très bien
dit à un peu abandonné on les accompagne
beaucoup plus fait par contre ce qui
fonctionne pas ou ceux qui tout
simplement veulent passer à autre chose
puis vous en avez la venons à mon bon si
vous pouvez faire deux points d'accord
déjà le premier formation initiale et
formation continue il ya eu un effort
qui a été fait évidemment ce que la
formation initiale avait été supprimée
par nicolas sarkozy on a rétabli les
écoles supérieures du professeur et de
l'éducation qui sont rebaptisés je crois
pas monsieur blanc coeur mais l'idée
c'était de reformer les profs comme
c'était incroyable que le seul métier
qui ne s'apprennent pas c'était celui
d'apprendre aux autres donc maintenant
ça ça prend un nouveau puisque la
pédagogie c'est quand même pas nul donc
ça vous avez pointé un problème de
l'éducation nationale centrale c'est la
formation continue a beau avoir été bien
formés en formation initiale
rien que l'apprentissage des
technologies numériques les nouvelles
pédagogies on a besoin d'être re
mobiliser sur le central sur évidemment
la carrière je ne peux qu'approuver
effectivement lors là pour le coup il ya
un petit saut budgétaire qui ne va pas
est petit non mais c'est extrêmement
important parce que moi je suis content
qu'on rallye de plus en plus de deux
parlementaires de citoyens à cette idée
qu'il est indispensable d'avoir des
profs mieux formés dans la durée quitte
à ce qu'on négocie avec eux et le point
alors là où tout avait offert avec à ce
quitte à ce qu'on négocie avec eux
l'organisation de l'année scolaire des
temps de vacances des vacances d'été
vous savez qu'en fait la réalité ce
n'est pas tellement les professeurs qui
bloque alors on peut mais c'est pas eux
qui font le les premiers à bloquer
l'arrêter c'est que c'est l'industrie du
tourisme qui a toujours voulu qu'on ne
touche pas à la question des vacances
scolaires parce qu'elle remettra en
cause en partie du chiffre d'affaires de
son métier vers minutes on mange
maintenant mais la question du statut si
c'est pour remettre en cause le statut
de la fonction publique
le fait d'avoir d'être fonctionnaires
avec 20 des nouveaux dribbles j'ai
compris et comme les cheminots
wilbur moi je pense que honnêtement
aujourd'hui remettre en cause le
principe sur laquelle vous avez la
garantie de votre emploi ce qui veut pas
dire que vous pouvez que vous êtes
protégé en tout pour rester dans une
classe ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
puis je vous dire on recrute aujourd'hui
des contractuels remplaçant avec des
comment dire une semaine
de formation s'il n'est pas de femmes à
ça je suis quand même comme des snipers
ça c'est des professeurs on se retrouve
avec des professions il y en a deux la
précarité c'est un doux mais mes droits
et devoirs il faut que si je suis
maintenant 18 ans sacré n'en discute
mais mais si c'est pour remettre en
cause le principe du statut et que tel
que le propose monsieur mayer non par
contre que cette discussion s'ouvre et
je me rajouter une chose est ce qu'on
est prêt à considérer que le secteur
privé doit avoir des obligations en
matière de mixité sociale parce que ça
vient d'être encore redit par une étude
qui le dit de manière très claire
qu'est ce qui explique la ghettoïsation
c'est le fait qu'on peut contourner dans
les faits les obligations de mixité
sociale par le secteur privé
voilà une discussion que moi je souhaite
à voir avec le secteur privé je le sens
je le crois capable de la voix et de
rediscuter les termes de la convention
parce que si il n'y a pas de remise en
cause de cela je pense qu'on aura de
plus en plus une école publique qui sera
confronté à des inégalités de plus en
plus forte qu'elle aura du mal à gérer
et une école privée qui profitera sans
doute mais qui échappera à ses devoirs
qui doivent être su de tout le service
public d'éducation dont fait partie le
privé merci merci beaucoup monsieur n'a
pas participé à ce face à face sur une
maman merci encore maintenant nous
accueillons nos deux consoeurs des
chaînes parlementaires avec nous donc
brigitte boucher de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale et
oriane mancini de public sénat dont se
remet dames c'est à vous maintenant et
on change de sujet et on parle de didier
guillaume avec vous didier guillon qui
vient d'être nommé ministre de
l'agriculture sam ancien socialiste
était dans le même camp il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça est ce que c'est un bon
choix parce que c'est une belle prise de
guerre pour minecraft pour il était très
proche de manuel valls
contrairement à benoît hamon écoutez moi
je n'ai pas grand chose à dire sur
didier guillaume sur ses premières
déclarations sur lui voilà là encore on
prétend faire des gouvernements de
professionnels et on découvre que ce que
l'on nomme ignore jusqu'au éléments les
plus des plus basiques de la loi il
n'appartient pas aux scientifiques de
faire la preuve que le glyphosate est
dangereux il appartient aux producteurs
de glyphosate de faire la preuve qu'il
ne l'est pas c'est la loi et le mas des
10 et guillaume a dit exactement le
contraire
incroyable c'est rcc au ton prono
directeur général de monsanto et lui
demander de nice de l'agriculture soit
réuni un casting mais je ne sais pas si
à ce stade je dis simplement que moi je
sais et nous le savons et vous le savez
que ces pesticides sont responsables de
mort qu'ils sont responsables de cancers
qu'ils ont un impact dans l'alimentation
sur la santé des agriculteurs pour quand
ils l'utilisent mais aussi une
alimentation sur la santé des enfants
c'est tant et si bien qu'on cherche à le
remplacer qu'on peut très bien le
remplacer aujourd'hui puisque de toute
forme de modèle agricole l'om a enfin
dit que c'est un vin cancérogène
probable le klm fait des études depuis
1990 mais vous avez envie de prendre un
risque ou non mais vos enfants vous avez
envie de faire de jouer avec les
cancérogènes programme des progressions
à la mairie où il est inscrit dans la
constitution de la vème république
donc oui je considère que moi j'avais
dit dans l'élection présidentielle et en
ce moment là souvenez vous quand j'ai
parlé des perturbateurs endocriniens
tout le monde me demander mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc tout le monde en
parle aujourd'hui il a encore sept
avions pointé la réalité d'un modèle
aujourd'hui qui est celui de la société
française où l'on mange on respire
ils ont touché utilise des objets qui
peuvent être dangereux pour notre santé
alors le risque zéro n'existe pas il ya
même des professionnels qui peuvent
parfois ignoré un certain nombre de
leurs responsabilités mais je crois
aujourd'hui qu'il est venu le temps de
la responsabilité et à commencer par
toutes celles et ceux qui participent à
la chaîne alimentaire
ce que mange mes enfants ça m'importe et
je n'ai pas envie demain qu'on se
retrouve avec une multitude de
commentaires de maladies liées au
développement du système de
des métabolismes de nos enfants en lien
avec les perturbateurs endocriniens que
se développent des maladies chroniques
et des concerts en lien avec cela c'est
la responsabilité du président de la
république c'est la responsabilité tous
les ministres y compris le ministre de
l'agriculture que de prendre ces
dossiers en main et l'a renvoyé du
directeur général de monsanto 3t d'être
proche des lobbies et guillaume et côté
je sais pas qui lui a soufflé à
l'oreille mais là là là c'est à dire
c'est pas mon fait en ligne directe on a
l'impression de parler à des industriels
des pesticides ou des insecticides
on a aujourd'hui mais une multitude de
documentation sur le sujet et pardon de
dire oh regardez ce qui s'est passé
encore avec aux antilles avec le
chlordécone c'est-à-dire un territoire
entier jusque le la biodiversité les les
habitants les enfants à plusieurs
générations qui sont touchés par ces
produits qui étaient des produits
dangereux et quoi on devrait aujourd'hui
demandé aux scientifiques de faire la
preuve que c'est dangereux mais on le
sait didier guillaume pons on le sait et
tout le temps que vous perdez vous fait
courir un risque sanitaire majeur à ce
pays donc à un moment
comportez vous comme un ministre
défenseur de l'intérêt général et pas
comme un ministre qui est soucieux de
faire plaisir au petit lobby qui sont
pressés de l'entourer dès le lendemain
de sa nomination mais lesquin tardière
dans les pesticides c'est la
responsabilité du chef de l'état et ce
qu'il fallait interdire le glyphosate ce
qu'il fallait le mettre dans la loire
est fait je le relis je l'aurais fait
dans la loi je leur ai fait comme toute
une série de molécules dont on sait
qu'ils peuvent présenter un risque
oui doit s'appliquer le principe de
précaution je vous prendre un exemple
moi quand j'étais ministre de la
consommation j'ai été confronté à la
décision d'interdire ou pas le bisphénol
a et on m'avait dit exactement la même
chose ou attention ça pourra un
supprimer des emplois et 2 on ne sait
pas faire et on ne sait pas par quoi le
remplacer
eh bien on l'a interdit s'est passé quoi
ya pas eu un plan social et des
entreprises qui étaient florissantes ont
trouvé des processus et des process
industriel alternatif
c'est une question de volonté toi bien
des problèmes de la république c'est pas
les lobbys et lobbies défendant des
intérêts particuliers
le problème c'est la faiblesse des
politiques qui ne savent pas leur
résister
c'est ça et sur un ministre faible de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui
bon ben je n'ai pas dit qu'il sera donné
ce qui interdira glyphosate en 2020 vous
y croyez mais qu'il le fasse avant qu'il
arrive
autre couac c'est possible mais jamais
je me il essayait de se rattraper
christian quelqu'un annoncer avec la
soeur de rio bourg non parce que parce
que soyons précis dans trois ans on
réexaminera l'autorisation peut pas dire
qu'on interdira et si nos trois dont
nous dira mme on n'a pas trouvé
l'alternative
on ne sait pas comment faire que feront
une chose est certaine
oui et alors mais la commission
européenne ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle est mal inspiré si le glyphosate
était déjà interdite je vous assure je
vous assure que personne ne reviendrait
dessus
comment est ce que vous avez reçu les
propos cette fois de madame wargon sur
ben c'est propre aux anciens comme tel
travail est pour danone en faveur de
l'huile de palme qui nous dit on peut
être scientifiquement je ne sais pas a
des vertus effectivement pour
l'alimentation des plus jeunes mais sauf
que ça contribue à la déforestation
on est en train de vivre sous la menace
d'un réchauffement climatique d'ici
trois ans de plus de 2 degrés qui va
entraîner des phénomènes migratoires de
400 millions de personnes les
submersions sur le littoral ou parle de
st
et vous avez des gens pour vous dire
nous sommes à la tête d'une entreprise
verte
danone mais qui fait quand même beaucoup
de plastique et considère que l'huile de
palme est indispensable et mac il trouve
des alternatives et par ailleurs je vous
le dis parce que là les lobis et pas
simplement en l'occurrence la danone
total qui obtient puis une fiscalité
avantageuse sur l'huile de palme avec le
soutien de la majorité actuelle égalité
avantage à ce mini c'est pas normal
écoutez mais pardon de le dire à un
moment on voir là
en collant qui sont menacés mais le même
argument que le bisphénol toujours
pareil vous croyez qu aujourd'hui de
objectivement totale avec les profits
qu'ils font total est une entreprises
menacées non mais c'est pas sérieux ça
n'est pas sérieux est ce que vous après
un moment disons le clairement je dirais
deux soyons de que nous soyons de droite
de gauche ou du centre de rien du tout
mais mais là ce qui se passe c'est la
santé de nos enfants alors dans
seulement à changer c'est vraiment un
monde qui va être un vrai ce que vous
soutenez la fiscalité écologique
vous pouvez par exemple mais qui fait
flamber le prix du diesel à la plante et
qui mêle des familles dans la difficulté
est ce que là vous estimez que le
gouvernement a raison - bon droit non
mais même cette politique non mais je
trouve que c'est totalement malhonnête
de dire attention on est contre
l'écologie punitive vous savez ce parc
on est puni aujourd'hui par le fait
qu'on a une alimentation dans laquelle
il ya des produits qui sont des produits
qui atteignent à notre santé c'étaient
les familles pauvres
c'est pourquoi elles sont aujourd'hui
punis par le fait qu'elle n'ait pas
d'autre choix parfois en raison de leurs
revenus que justement de manger non pas
bio ce que mange tout ce qui leur donne
des leçons mais de manger d'acheter des
plats préparés dans les grandes surfaces
qui sont pas la meilleure alimentation
qui soit sur le pont l'equilibre
nutritifs crise sociale alors quoi alors
unis mais quand même le fait qu'ils
vivent dans des logements qui sont des
passoires énergétiques qu'ils vivent à
côté d'autoroute dans laquelle ils
respirent des particules fines vole un
parcours plus nantis renommée arrêté de
me dire qu'ils sont et discours royal a
dit ce qu'elle peut donc est-ce que vous
dire moi je considère par exemple que
demain oui le principe des péages
urbains de la gratuité des transports
publics savent sûr c'est le sens de
l'histoire
on ira vers cela et il faut développer
toutes les formes de fiscalité notamment
à l'endroit des plus modestes et des
plus pauvres pour qu'ils aient ou le
choix entre une alternative aux
déplacements dans leur véhicule ou
évidemment une compensation qui leur
permettent à eux d'être moins impacté
que les autres notamment les entreprises
quand ils utilisent des moteurs qui sont
évoqués en compensation mais pour
l'instant moi j'ai toujours été
favorable à ça mais ce que je vous dis
c'est que la meilleure remettons les
choses à l'endroit
au gendre et de nivelles pour bosser
quand bien punis tous les jours punis
tous les jours par l'air qu'on respire
parce qu'on mange donc il serait
peut-être temps qu'on regarde
qu'on y pense un tout petit peu plus à
moyen terme et l'avenir de nos enfants
plutôt que à très court terme est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que les leçons la
démission nicolas hulot ont été tirés
aucune et didier guillaume on est la
parfaite et madame wargon à l'écologie
mais incroyable des gens qui justifiait
les huiles de palme qui viennent
d'entreprise j'ai rien contre cette
entreprise mais qui quand même super
productrice de plastique
bon écoute et alors peut-être que c'est
son expertise en matière de 2,2 de
pollution qui lui donne une légitimité à
dépolluer maintenant mais je veux dire
c'est que voilà jeu
je voudrais vous prendre une mesure bon
bah je deux oursonnes ans dans les
pyrénées
c'est le bilan de monsieur doré
confiance on s'interrogeait c'est bien
parti
2 voilà rien arriver il vient d'arriver
oui bah écoutez sur glyphosate sur ces
sujets importants sur le nucléaire sûr
vous voyez quelque chose sur la
fiscalité sur les huiles de palme au
coup je vais vous dire une chose je vous
en parlais avec eux sincèrement si on
pense que on doit commencer à faire
d'écologie là où les intérêts
économiques s'arrête on fera pas
d'écologie oui il y aura forcément des
grands intérêts privés qui verront leur
trajectoire de croissance remise en
cause par la transition écologique
mais là encore faucon hiérarchise je
vous le redis avec beaucoup de sincérité
la dette financière ça se rembourse
parce que quelqu'un a détient la dette
écologique quand tu as eu la fonte des
pôles ça ne se rembourse pas ça n'est
pas une affaire de 20 ans c'est
maintenant classe au regard de mancini
pendant j'ai su je sujet vous êtes
favorable à la pma pour tout comme le
veut le gouvernement est ce que vous
pensez que la société prête à ce qu'il
n'y a pas de risque de fracture comme ça
a été le cas sur l'ariège forte hausse
mais la société préférée en avance sur
les politiques les peureux sont les
politiques sur la fin de vie la société
est en avance sur les politiques nous
n'avançons pas parce que les politiques
sont peureux et mâcon ne montera pas sur
la fin de vie
pas davantage qui est bon alors
peut-être que j'espère qu'il le fera
pour la pma pour tout mais dans la
vieille ville est comme moi je les dis
j'ai pris position pour l'élection
présidentielle ce suis favorable car m
qui permettent
oui de faciliter la fin de vie au delà
des soins palliatifs où cela de
l'endormissement tel qu'il est permis
aujourd'hui par la loi le cas de steve
ans et a su en profiter
non c'est une maison où la personne est
en réalité aujourd'hui savons que sa
majorité de la population qui est que
l'on avance donc souvent les citoyens
sont en avance sur les politiques
est ce que fait emmanuel macron sur la
pma par exemple c'est bon renvoyer une
nouvelle commission
ça me semble-t-il c'est cela le soin de
nous dire ce qu'il doit en être bon
c'est tout ça à peu près on a eu des
comités d'éthique tout le monde a parlé
bon il la pma c'est pas la gpa c'est pas
le même sujet les fans qui n'autorise
que la pma aujourd'hui peut conduire à
la de conduire la gpa moyen terme est ce
que c'est aussi je ne vois pas je crois
pas je vais quand même où je suis je ne
suis pas favorable par exemple favorable
à pma mais pourquoi je ne suis pas
favorable à gpa parce qu'il ya un tiers
et intervient à dire qui contractualise
ray le fait de louer en quelque sorte
son ventre que ce tiers peu
s'interroger à un moment sur le fait de
garder ou de ne pas garder que ceux
tirés souvent pauvres effet des enfants
pour des personnes plus riches
donc voilà il me semble aujourd'hui non
je vous aide pour l'égalité est ce qu
entre légalité un de couple de femmes et
l'égalité de couples d'hommes on viendra
pas inévitablement la gpr non mais c'est
pas comme cela que je se poserait ci
représentent les choses comme ça c'est
aux douze éléments le droit vous êtes
pour le droit à l'enfant pour 2 pharma
l'occurrence pour le droit la musique et
une troisième personne qui pouvait femme
qui est une femme qui elle va faire un
enfant si cet enfant par exemple
présentent un handicap c'est que comme
on le voit les personnes finalement
décidé de ne pas prendre l'enfant
si on se retrouve avec une situation
dans laquelle en fait on constate que ce
sont toujours des femmes pauvres qui
choisissent cela pour pouvoir faire des
enfants je ne crois pas que ce soit
respectable viré par la frontière une
limite c'est que je pense que le marché
ne peut pas rentrer là dedans et en même
temps moi qui suis papa le désir
d'enfant
comment vous dire je le comprends mais
l'adoption elle est permise pour les
ailes étaient déjà dans les faits visuel
mais elle est permise pour les couples
homosexuels et se dit juste mais je sais
que c'est difficile mais ce que je veux
vous je ce désir d'enfant je le
comprends mais il me semble que par la
gpa c'est pas que touchons là à une
question plus fondamentale à d'autres
sujets d'actu le social sur la prochaine
grande réforme au menu du gouvernement à
la réforme des retraites on a compris
vos inquiétudes concernant les
professeurs mais est-ce qu'il ya quand
même du bon dans cette réforme des
retraites
est ce que c'est une réforme que vous
pourriez soutenir non non parce que je
pense qu'elle ne répond pas aux
problèmes que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
je pense que le but de cette réforme est
de faire des économies sur le système
alors avant tout des économies comme on
a logé la durée de cotisation maintenant
vous avez compris et que la réforme par
points on va payer moins de pension on
va payer moins d'impôts en tout ce sont
les retraités qui partiront avec une
retraite titre de retraite plus faible
dans les deux cas on réfléchit en termes
d'économie que l'on fait sur la sécurité
sociale c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je préconise deux axes
la première c'est celle de mettre à
contribution je le redis la richesse
produite par les machines c'est à dire
que on ou réfléchissent plus dans les
cotisations sociales qui financent les
retraites en fonction du nombre de
salariés en fonction de la richesse
produite par une entreprise si une
entreprise fait 10 millions d'euros avec
100 salariés où elle fait 10 millions
d'euros avec 20 salariés elle doit payer
les mêmes cotisations
aujourd'hui à 20 salariés vous payez
cinq fois moins de cotisations 400
salariés première réforme et la deuxième
réforme qui est pour mes yeux la plus
essentielle est de nous parle pas le
gouvernement
c'est la question de la pénibilité parce
que la principale inégalités c'est au
moment où vous partez à la retraite
vous avez une espérance de vie plus
courte quand vous avez été employés
ouvriers mais une espérance de vie en
bonne santé encore plus court
nous sommes là on n'a pas réglé le
problème sous le précédent quinquennat
pas assez il a fait mais pas assez et
surtout ça a été remis en cause en
partie par emmanuel macron qui a
supprimé
l'exposition risques chimiques tenez
vous bien comme facteur de paix ni
mailing emmanuel macron surpression noki
du medef
vous vous trouvez pas ça aujourd'hui
insupportable et insoutenable vous avez
une vie à bosser au contact de produits
chimiques dans une entreprise de chimie
vous savez qu'il ya des risques
votre retraite va être plus courte et en
plus en bonne santé encore plus courte
aucun facteur de pénibilité des prêts en
compte pour partir plus tôt et bien
voilà les deux priorités changer le mode
de financement pour ne pas baisser les
retraites et tenir compte de la paix ni
la femme elle a pour but aussi de mettre
fin aux régimes spéciaux n'a 42
aujourd'hui est ce que vous vous dites
il faut conserver les régimes spéciaux
témoin je pense que le régime de la
comédie-française sais pas ce qui fait
qu'il ya un problème dans le système de
retraite se comprend la démarche mais si
à la fin c'est 2 2
réduire la retraite des fonctionnaires
remettant en cause le calcul de leur
trêve retraite même si on tient compte
des primes d'andy et des professions où
il n'y a pas de prime ont quasiment pas
de prime les professeurs pourquoi j'en
ai parlé parce qu'il a quasiment pas de
pluie donc dans les faits ils vont avoir
une retraite qui va baisser
vous trouvez ça normes ce et ceux à qui
on confie nos enfants aurore des
retraites qui baisse bon bah moi je
pointe tout cela je le dis cette réforme
elle va avoir des conséquences sur le
niveau des pensions que les retraités
d'avenir s'y préparent ils auront alors
dernière 13,3 en paix parce que très
concrètement on aura des la valeur du
point
il ya un système complémentaire c'est
déjà par point mais valeur du point là
perdu 30% alors question la dernière de
l'émission comme un mot sur l'italie
vous avez dit tout à l'heure je ne suis
pas d'accord avec le fonctionnement des
traités l'italie engagé un bras de fer
avec bruxelles sur son budget il refuse
de modifier ce que matteo salvini a
raison de tenir tête à la coloration
face à deviner vous faites on les fait
pas le droit de dire ça il est ministre
de l'intérieur il ya un premier ministre
commence à peine s'il est ce que la
convertir en italien le mariage des
jeunes ouïgours pas il d'ailleurs c'est
bien pour celle de nouvelles planches
que quentin 50 et quant à nicole
fasciste fait la politique qu'il fait
qu'ils inspirent d'autres gouvernements
libéraux sur les migrants je me
demandais mais je revendique que la
grandeur de la nation française c'est à
dire le contraire de l'italie
premièrement mais je dit autre chose
c'est que quand il ya une commission
européenne qui n'a d'autres rôles que
d'empêcher les nations de construire
leur budget selon la volonté de leur
peuple à un moment avec la négociation
c'est le bâton ou le bâton je pense
qu'on va tout droit dans le mur alors la
raison pour laquelle tu veux le dire en
face et leurs familles mais je pense que
chaque fois que j'entends juncker ou
moscovici parlait sur ces questions là
mais s'ils ne se rendent pas compte
qu'on clair aujourd'hui
leur discours est un discours qui
renforce effectivement l'europhobie oui
il faut des négociations oui il faut des
discussions mais mais cette attitude qui
est une attitude d'absolu comédiens
n'ont pas fermeté mais dureté
indifférence aux états membres ne paraît
pas et de la bd reste 30 secondes et on
a envie d'avoir votre réponse
sur l'arabie saoudite après la mort du
journaliste jamal khashoggi est-ce qu'il
faut rompre les relations commerciales
avec ce pays
en tout cas il faut arrêter d'être
saoudo dépendants parce qu'alors la d'un
gouvernement à un autre on a couru les
faveurs des rois saoudien et il me
semble que ce gouvernement hélas en
raison des contrats militaires
d'armements et c est avec la pression de
l'industrie d'armement n'est pas
réellement sur la voie de changer cela
je pense que non honnêtement à un moment
à qui va-t-on des armes et et à quel
prix
à quel prix alors c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup
mesdames merci benoît hamon je ne sais
pas si vous mesurez ce n'est pas
l'engouement que vous soulevez sur le
site à mon amour c'est un site de
rencontres de célibataires pro am on
vous suivez ça un peu les coûts cachés
mais j'espère qu'ils feront beaucoup
d'enfants très bien merci à vous a
travaillé de tous